dawn over kiev after a quieter night
they had prepared all weekend cleaning
weapons mustering for deployment
but the onslaught still hasn't come
if putin doesn't care about his citizens
the more reasons why he can spare
strangers
people for him are only garbage
both his people and strangers
former boxing champion and kiev mayor
vitaly klitschko has this message for
the invaders go back home
you have nothing to find here we hope
the russians take the decision move back
to russia
they nothing to find here in our home
the russian advance may have stalled its
troops in its armour not moving at the
pace that have been feared with reports
it's disorganized and in places in
disarray
though not here stanisia luhanska is
ukraine says the banner but russian
troops have taken the town in eastern
ukraine it's soldiers taking up
positions outside banks and other key
buildings
this footage shows the impact of a
russian cruise missile strike on an
airport in northwest ukraine allegedly
launched from belarus
and here from another angle
but on the border with belarus russian
and ukrainian diplomats are due to meet
later
russian leader vladimir putin may
yesterday have put his nuclear
deterrence forces on raised alert
but it's also it seems giving diplomacy
a chance before the fighting might
resume in earnest
dominic waghorn sky news
moscow